grüß gott und herzlich willkommen aus
der maria theresien kaserne in wien
heute am dienstag workout mit dem
rucksack ein rucksack werk hat sozusagen
gestern war man auch beim theraband mit
der frau korporal hufnagel
heute ist der gehry da es ist der herr
peter richter peter ebner und wir machen
mit euch gemeinsam ein workout zur
stabilität von eurem körper das heißt
herr um stabilität in kombination mit
allgemeiner muskelarbeit aber wie gesagt
wir haben gesagt wir nehmen den rucksack
als hilfsmittel für euch zu hause als
variante ein buch hinein ein dickes apa
kleine bücher hinein
wir haben eines entdeckt haben keppel
pelster mit denen kann man das natürlich
auch perfekt trainieren aber so dass ihr
problemlos mit trainieren keins haben
gesagt rucksack ist perfektes
hilfsmittel dazu das training mit der
kette bell an sich ist sehr dynamische
variante um explosiv die ehrung von
stütz kraft zu entwickeln
das wäre man mit euch heute auslassen
das heißt wenn er in einer statischen
variante ohne viel schwingen machen weil
dafür braucht sie einen personal trainer
dafür braucht sie braucht jemanden der
euch entsprechend unterstützt und ich
wirklich nicht nur auf die finger
sondern indem wir auf den rücken schaut
dass der stabile ist weil der kamera
wirklich etwas kaputt machen aber heute
unser werk hat ist für euch herr
abgebrochen heruntergebrochen
das war das verletzungsfrei und mit
hoher belastung über die bühne kriegen
seid ihr bereit gary herbert sind bereit
das heißt fangen wir an mit aufwärmen
wir bauen heute die schnur springen
wieder mit ein wir bauen es einmal
methodisch auf so dass die die
vielleicht nicht ganz so gut springen
können dass ein bisschen üben können das
heißt nämlich einfach einmal eure sprung
nur zur hand und die erste übung bevor
man überhaupt hinein steigt und springt
ist einfach einmal das schwingen der
schnur auf der seite und gleichzeitig
dazu bewegen und dazu hüpfen in den
rhythmus wie sich die schnur bewegt und
das versucht am besten jetzt gerne nach
zu machen die die keine sprung namen
bewegen sich einfach am stand das ist in
ordnung und stand laufen hand beim
anspringen und die anderen wechseln
einmal die seite sprung zur seite
wechseln das heißt in die zweite hand
nehmen und auf der zweiten hand das
ganze gleich auch weiter weiter üben
[Applaus]
da kam eric 30 sekunden oder minuten
lang das ganze machen wir machen wir mal
kurze pause kurz mal aus lockern arme
kreisen vorwärts wir mobilisieren ein
bisserl dazu und die wird 10 über das
normale schwingen auf der seite über
achter bewegungen vor dem körper bis hin
zum einsteigen und schnur springen
damals das jetzt im aufwärmprogramm kurz
an um rückwärts kreisen und gegen gleich
die arme kreisen
und da wichtig beim heutigen workout
drücken ich stabil unter spannung
muskulär ist es vorbereitet und darf nie
in keiner situation aufgelöst werden das
beginnt beim anheben des gewichts und
endet wieder beim absetzen
ok ich gesagt zweiter durchgang sprung
schnur probier mal auf der seite
beginnen und dann in einer achter
bewegung vor dem körper dass immer
wieder die richtung zu wechseln und das
einzubauen
[Applaus]
und er setzt das funktioniert eigentlich
da los die nehmen sich hat bei euch zu
hause wenn man das schon langsam und
locker anfangt und aufbaut dann ist es
im bereich des möglichen dass man das
relativ rasch lernt die dies koordinativ
herausfordernd haben wohin so wie es der
herbert taschek macht hat ihr könnt
natürlich die hand wieder wechseln mit
der linken hand das ganze machen mit der
rechten hand das ganze machen und wo wir
zimmer im rhythmus der schnur dazu zu
springen
ok kurze pause kurz aus lockeren
sprüchen wieder zur seite
wir beginnen wieder mit dem oberkörper
verdrehen das heißt wir nehmen den
ganzen körper tränen von der linken auf
die rechte seite
das becken geht in der bewegung mit der
kopf geht in der bewegung mit das heißt
wir haben einmal den gesamten körper in
bewegung wechseln einfach 3459 hin und
her
danach jetzt fixieren das becken das
heißt es dreht sich der oberkörper mit
dem kopf hin und her dann kriegen wir
spielen ganz einen anderen teil der
wirbelsäule thema in der rotation der
belasten und auf wir haben und das
dritte variante fix ihr mal den kopf
auch noch dazu und drehen nur den rumpf
in der mitte zwischen becken und kopf
hin und jahr ein stabiles becken halten
in der opposition unter blick geradeaus
was ist so wichtig beim schnur springern
auf was ist jetzt zu achten wenn man in
die in die schnur quasi ein steigt also
die schnur muss lang genug sein wenn ich
im einsteiger leicht am ellenbogen
gelenke
[Applaus]
alternativ lassen beide beine springen
und ganz wichtig versucht nicht zu hoch
wegzuspringen das ist auch fehler dem am
anfang oft noch dass man möglichst hoch
wegspringen
dann braucht man natürlich hat man lange
flugreisen die schon wieder da wenn man
in einer andern ist das mieten aber
schon wieder weg sein das heißt nur kurz
weg springen vom boden die schnur
rutscht unterhalt durch und es geht
schon weiter
okay sagt uns vielleicht ein name wie
das einsteigen auf der seite drehen und
dann einsteigen
genauso kann ich ein und aussteigen in
die bewegung ohne dass sie mal die
zeichen an haus oder die schnur auf den
hinterkopf einmal kurze pause einmal
genutzt um schubert finden herbert ja
das kann passieren beim schnur springern
beim bewegen überhaupt kein problem
wir mobilisieren weiter wir kreisen in
der hüfte und richtung wechseln
thema des halbleiter im stand oberkörper
tränen in der vorbeuge nehmen wir
kleider zu gehen alle müssen halt
schauen dass man den körper richtig gut
vorbereiten auf die belastung die jetzt
kommt weil die spannung dort zu halten
mit dem externen mit dem zusatzgewicht
mit dem rucksack mit dem sandberg oder
mit der kette weil das ist eine hohe
belastung für den körper
und dann muss man sich zeit vorbereiten
okay wenn man zweiter kniegelenk beide
zusammen hände auflegen und geht schon
schöne kreise schön durch rotieren
richtung wechseln noch einmal richtung
wechseln
und nehmen wir keine sprunggelenk gibt
sprunggelenk am boden kreisen und die
richtung wechseln seite wechseln
richtung wechseln kurzausflug eine halbe
minute 34 minute nochmals nur springen
probiert es noch einmal richtig
einsteigen richtig aussteigen seitlich
drehen dazu bewegen und ohne sprung
schnell laufen am stand fox abschalten
boxen alle möglichen varianten
hantelmann springen
schaut einfach dass der kreislauf in
schwung kommt man kann ja jetzt das
tempo zu erhöhen man hört einander
frequenz der schnur wenn man das kann
[Applaus]
gehen sie konnten
und wieder kurze schnur sprung bause
sprung in der pause hatte laut
durcheinander ist strukturiert von oben
nach unten gegangen
jetzt nehmen hat den ellbogen her arme
seitlich hoch geben im elb umkreisen
da auch da der blick geradeaus
oberkörper ist aufrecht brust die stolz
richtung wechseln hände zusammen
enke die braucht man additional belastet
unter spannung heute schon mal alles mal
entsprechend aufwärmen können richtung
wechseln
genau und dann macht man auch die heiße
teile noch einmal speziell dazu wir
haben es zwar schon beim rotieren beim
drehen des oberkörpers mit trainern
gehabt aber noch einmal extra blick
wendung links abrollen über die rechte
seite und der bäume hin und her rollen
und einmal noch körper mehr ausschnitt
und damit durch schütteln jetzt die die
brav mit trainieren seit mittlerweile
über drei wochen ihr wisst was 47
bedeutet für die die vielleicht jetzt
erst das erste mal eingestiegen
gestiegen sind 477 regel stets 7
kniebeugen sie tabs und sieben mal den
rücken aufrichten und das machen wir
jetzt in einem stück durchgeht schloss
auch da fehlt es varianten die für euch
passen meint 7 normale liegestütz zu
wenig sind oder normale liegestütz nicht
gehen kann ich sie habe so dynamischer
machen hineinspringen bei den kniebeugen
genauso jetzt da fürs aufwärmen normal
aber im zweiten durchgang kann so leicht
weg springen immer schauen dass die
dynamik in die bewegung hinein krieg
zieht ab dazu und generell sollte der
fragen zu den übungen haben ja stellt
das postet das kommentiert das video
werden natürlich regelmäßig und
jederzeit beantwortet auch hier die
zweifach variante rückenstrecke und
sieht es mit dabei
und die letzte übung 7 wiederholungen
rücken aufrichten da jetzt wichtig oder
schwung ohne reißen nur mit der
muskelkraft
das heißt 47 hammer einmal aufstehen
eine aktivierung fürs herz kreislauf
system bauen wir noch mit 1
das heißt einmal hand beim anspringen
start schnell stopp langsam weiter
springen geht los hohes tempo hohe
frequenz braun stopp normal weiter statt
ein stopp normal weiter einmal noch
start stopp und aus locker letzte jungen
aus dem auf ihren prozess der mount ein
paar wichtige übung um die rom
stabilität zu trainieren oder
entsprechend mich muskulär und im gelenk
darauf vorzubereiten was jetzt für
belastung kommt und die stabilität ist
jetzt ein großes thema deswegen
baumaterial mit einem linksschuss
ausgangsstellung 20 sekunden martin
kämper und los knie geht zur brust
dynamisch voran zurück kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule so gut wie
es geht eine stolze brust machen das
heißt die brust trotzdem auf und gerade
rücken genau nach 321 auslauf
durchschlafen ein schluck trinken
rucksack errichten weil jetzt fangen wir
mit dem training an
obwohl das aufwärmen für viele
vielleicht schon sehr belastend wird es
ist ganz wichtig wenn die hohe belastung
danach ob muss ja im aufwärmen das
einbauen um entsprechend leistungsfähig
zu sein und keine verletzungen
davonzutragen
die alle register fühlst du gut bist
fit und bereit das hören wir gerne das
heißt zusatzgerät schnappen an rucksack
eine tasche eine kette bei irgendwas was
das gewicht hat als sechster tragen
wasser ist genauso gut ja irgendwas was
er bislang zusatzgewicht hauptmann satz
mit dabei und man kann die übungen sehr
gut miteinander trainieren
die erste übung das ding schott gerrits
und ist einmal vor
gerade positionen aus dem rücken beim
hochheben und ihr spannt die muskulatur
an so dass der rücken stabil ist und der
träger gewicht vor dem körper danke gary
der arbeit mit der tasche simuliert mit
einer sandbank jetzt geht das genauso
man muss schauen dass man den griff
findet und entsprechendes koordiniert
dass die hand vorne und hinten das ganze
über gibt macht sich bereit
richter zusatzgewicht hier in 15
sekunden staat mit 30 sekunden slingshot
das heißt das gewicht bewegen rund um
den körper ganz wichtig gerade rücken
beim anheben geraderücken beim absetzen
und sowieso beim üben folgerung spannung
sei aber bereit 21 gewicht hoch und los
geht's und wenn das tempo zu schnell ist
was anschlags macht das langsame lieber
stabil und ein bisschen langsamer als
wie schnell und dafür instabil
halbzeit ist vorbei kann es gerne einmal
die richtung wechseln oberkörper bleibt
stabil kopf bleibt gerade rücken ist
gerade brust stolz nach vorne noch 2 1
und gerade das gewicht wieder absetzen
wie wir mal kniebeuge macht das klappt
also das gewicht ablegen und nennen
rundrücken das gewicht runter weil dann
belaste ich meine wirbelsäule die
bandscheiben bereich wo es nicht
brauchen kann
ok
hammer den flieger zweite übung was
machen was nächstes jahr
hey das ist der heiligenschein das heißt
dass eine über kopfbewegung für diese
über kopfbewegung schauen uns noch ganz
schnell noch mal die schuld an wie die
beweglichkeit da drin ist das heißt wir
machen eine große am kreisel rückwärts
das einfach aus der position große
kreise rückwärts mit a bisserl dynamik
dass wenn man jetzt über kopf arbeiten
dass da nix sein kann und vorwärts
kreisen algerischer bereit ist es der
ist richtig unter strom
ok bereit machen herbert sagst aber vor
der übung mit der tasche ihr nehmt das
wieder gerade hoch vor dem körper und
dreht die hände
das gewicht rund um den kopf biete pass
auf dass du etwas gewicht am kopfhaut
auf die nase haut oder wo er immer das
heißt genügend abstand lassen nach 15
sekunden macht mal wieder ein
richtungswechsel und wie gesagt macht
sich bereit in 15 sekunden statt mal los
mit der übung halo das hat der
heiligenschein bewegung kreisförmig rund
um den kopf was sie konnten gewicht her
nehmen gerade anheben 53 21 und 30
sekunden halo das heißt die bewegung im
heiligenschein rund um den kopf jetzt
jedes mal die richtung wechseln oder
ähnlich gesagt in fünf sekunden weil
dann haben wir die halbzeit der bewegung
des trainings dieser einheit macht
halbzeit wäre das heißt jetzt die
richtung wechseln wer nicht jedes mal
gewechselt hat und das jetzt schon darum
muss gespannt sein da braucht volle
power
der rücken hat volle power da gibt es
kein links und rechts aussuchen
da muss volle muskelspannung seien sei
das aus 30 sekunden sind durch und
wieder gerade das gewicht ablegen keine
bewegung kein rundrücken immer stabil
muskulär gesicherte wirbelsäule die
dritte übung machen
herbert ist okay
mädchen als kniebeugen schulter drücken
wir schauen uns jetzt gern sagt uns das
bitte einmal vor okay das heißt wir
nehmen das gewicht vor dem körper den
rucksack die tasche was auch immer
machen eine kniebeuge danke und stoßen
das gewicht nach oben
das heißt wir einerseits die beine die
belastet sind und andererseits die
schultern und die oberarme das heißt
eine komplexe übung eine ganzkörper
übung die richtige intensiv ist das
heißt vorbereiten
zehn sekunden dann legen wir los 30
sekunden belastungs zeit 5 21 uhr los
geht's kniebeuge mit anstoßen nach oben
und wie es jetzt bei den 2 die wissen
was sie tun
der körper ist unter strom der ist unter
spannung gibt es keine ausreichend links
und rechts das ist wie auf schienen und
das ist ganz wichtig bei der kniebeuge
auch beinachse beachten hochspannung ist
da 3 hat es geschafft fünf sekunden noch
21 und gewicht ab auch hier wieder
gerade ablegen keine position für die
wirbelsäule die nicht gut ist
durchschlafen gehe hier wird das war
richtig anstrengend
die muskelgruppe etwas kleiner das hat
jetzt mal kleine und oberarme und
schultern mit dabei jetzt nehmen wir mal
den unteren rücken her das heißt good
morning skripten strecke im bereich der
lendenwirbelsäule hauptsächlich die
beanspruchte muskulatur und schaue man
sich dann gerne dafür die bieten einmal
die good morning vorzuzeigen
ihr nehmt ihr gewicht wieder gerade hoch
geht in die beiden strecken und jetzt
kommt die bewegung nur aus dem
oberkörper nach vor und wieder hoch und
nach vor und wieder auch muss gar nicht
zu tief seien wichtig ist schultern
zurückziehen schulterblätter fixieren
und dort bleiben
okay in 15 sekunden legen wir los
bereitmachen nach fünf sekunden 21
workout und jetzt darauf achten wirklich
die schulterblätter hinten zu lassen
kämpfen um die position des geraden
rückens sehr gut
wo steht dass der rucksack ist eine
kette bell ist oder ein sechster tragen
wasser gewichtsbelastung ist drauf und
dann müssen wir muskulär gut abgesichert
sein
gerade im unteren rücken ganz wichtig
und natürlich mein oben der rücken
stabiles schaut des comics fünf sekunden
3 absatz 2 1 und kurze pause jetzt haben
wir den rücken gehabt
machen wir den bau kann ich ja etwas
machen wir auch die tabs die klassische
übung haben wir schon in vielen
varianten kennengelernt
heute macht man es mit einem
zusatzgewicht das bitte nur dann noch
nach wenn das wirklich stabil halten
kann wenn das noch zu vieles führen
bauch dann einfach sie tipps ohne
zusatzgewicht aber jetzt schauen wir uns
einmal die variante an
das gewicht den rucksack die tasche vor
der brust nach oben strecken und in die
position aufrichten
wenn das so vieles gewicht vor die brust
ist genauso anstrengend und hohe
belastung aber heute nicht ganz so hoch
ok kurz noch aus lockern bauchmuskel
noch kurz entspannen weil in zwölf
sekunden geht es wieder los mit den 30
sekunden belastungs zeit das ganze ist
natürlich auch mit der cattle bell
möglich und ein a nicht möglich das
sagte kerry und wird es dann aber im
werk machen
das ist die hohe kunst des trainings
firmbach zeit läuft 30 sekunden und los
geht's
spannung muss da sein spannung ist da
wenn er merkt es geht nicht immer ganz
so gut dann entsprechend das gewicht vor
die brust nehmen
halbzeit ist ist durch das heißt gewicht
wechseln und wieder los klein ob es
geschafft nach 21 zeit durch 30 sekunden
bauchmuskel belastung h mannschaft sehr
gut
jetzt haben wir schon ganz früh jetzt
fehlt eigentlich nur noch eine trug eine
übung zu drücken drücken eine zum ziehen
als eine push und eine polygame auspuff
was machen wir
was kann denn jedes worker deine der
anleger stets danke herbert genau jetzt
die variante liegestütz mit
zusatzbelastung das heißt es nicht
gewicht mit dem man die liegestütze
machen also mir kennt uns natürlich den
rucksack auf den rücken legen
das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr machen
die liegestütz ganz normal 30 sekunden
sind lang genug aber wir nehmen das als
erhöhung das ist ein bisserl instabil
für die hände und da aus dem handgelenk
zu stabilisieren bei der kette
also das ist jetzt die variante
liegestütz den wir jetzt anbieten dass
wir möchten ganz kurzen ob dieser
angerufen oder vorbereiten die gelenke
noch das durchschnitt und fünf sekunden
position einnehmen
3211 jetzt 30 sekunden liegestütz am
zusatzgerät nicht mit zusatzgerät
sondern ein zusatzgerät
halbzeit ist geschafft 15 sekunden
arbeitszeit wie gesagt achtet auf eure
körperspannung das beginnt beim
sprunggelenk und endet in wahrheit beim
kopf das heißt der kopf ist hier in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule der bauch
ist gespannt
die gerade ist da und arbeiten 21 30
sekunden porsche übung erledigt es ist
richtig anstrengend ja das sieht man das
kriegt man mit ihr spürt das zuhause das
heißt kurz die hohe ausschüttung
regenerieren ganz kurz gema in die
nächste übung dies nicht minder
anstrengend das ist die zuführung die
pole übung das heißt eine retro sagt uns
dass vorgänge bitte hier geht es wieder
in die liegestütz ausgangsstellung und
hebt einarmiger gewicht im wechsel hoch
dabei achten drücken gerade stolzer
brust die arbeit wie magst du ihm stehen
das heißt das zusatzgewicht vor dem
körper hochheben das den eltern seitlich
vorbei hochziehen das gewicht also
einiges rudern im stehen oder wer die
kette welt zuhause hat reinicke draw aus
der liegestütz position zehn sekunden
volle kanne belastung gleich soweit
positionen einnehmen 4321 und da ist
ganz wichtig die stabilität aus dem
becken damals volle power drin sein der
rücken muss stabil sein muss gerade sein
und das ganze natürlich auch im stehen
ja das heißt beide varianten da dazu
geht das gewicht zum körper nach oben
frei hauptsatz zehn sekunden nur
stabiler rücken stabile beine kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule nur die
arme arbeiten 321 zeit es aus
[Applaus]
durchschnaufen aus locken hohe belastung
man spürt man hört man sieht's ja das
ist richtig richtig anstrengend letzte
übung hammer aus diesem sammelsurium an
ganz körperübungen das ist der achter
des mit dem rucksack befand relativ
schwierig das heißt es ausprobieren die
tasche so nehmen dass sie auch
eine acht drehen kann es daher wird sagt
euch das lieber hier langsam und stabil
bevor er sich den rucksack in die
kniekehle haut ja da schauen dass man
rund durch seine beine durchkommt und
das ganze mit einer stabilen beinachse
einen geraden rücken und das ganze in
einer dynamischen bewegung also viel
spaß konzentriert sich darauf bleibt
stabil das ist das wichtige in zehn
sekunden legen wir los
der achter noch 51 los geht's und
natürlich auch mit der kette bell worauf
80 ich muss auf meinen gespannten
geraden stabilen rücken achten das heißt
da bauch muss gespannt sein
der rücken muss gespannt sein der ganze
körper ist stabil und geht nur die kugel
zwischen den beinen durch halbzeit lange
vorbei noch zehn sekunden gerade rücken
stabile position das ist ganz wichtig im
herrenbereich an mir zu arbeiten ja war
super g sei es durch 30 sekunden kurze
pause kurz durchschnaufen
es ist anstrengend ich hab's versprochen
ja und wenn da haben mit dabei sein
genauso fleißig und genauso in dem
trainingsmodus wieder gerne und der
herbert niewerth zu spüren es ist
wirklich körperlich fordernd und wir
machen jetzt noch einen zweiten
durchgang mit euch ja wobei den zweiten
durchgang werden auf einer belastungs
zeiten immer 30 sekunden nehmen sondern
ich glaube 20 sekunden reichen jetzt für
ein zweiten durchgang voll und ganz so
dass gewährleistet ist dass ihr die rum
spannung entsprechend aufrechterhalten
könnte was fällt dir ein wo passt es
militärisch hinein dieses workout
das militär gibt ja immer tragen wer von
schleudern
also alles was man schnell kräftig und
mit kraft ausdauer maximalkraft machen
muss basken hat es überall wo ihren
perfekten transfer von der oberen auf
die unteren extremität hat oder
umgekehrt von der unteren auf die obere
richtig beim überwinden von hindernissen
beim werfen von von wahnsinn
handgranaten oder sonstigen beim heben
und tragen überall dort habe einen kraft
transfer und die brauchen natürlich die
entsprechende power aus meinen ruhm
voraus und dekane nicht nur statisch
trainieren so wie man sie in den stütz
übungen gemacht haben und sondern auch
dynamisch und auch dynamisch mit
zusatzgewicht das ist so
der letzte stufe quasi des ausbaus in
der rumpf kraft das dynamische
explosiver entwickeln und bei sk mit
zusatzgewicht mit dem rucksack mit der
kette mit einer tasche perfekt
trainieren aber bereits in durchgang
nummer zwei okay wir machen 20 sekunden
belastungs zeit und dann 20 sekunden
pause
damit reduzieren wir das ganze ein
bisserl und die spannung kann man
hoffentlich dann entsprechend
aufrechthalten staatenlos 15 sekunden
name durchschlafen bereitmachen noch
zehn sekunden erste übung der styling
schott das heißt das drehen des gewichts
rund um den körper in drei sekunden
geht's los das ist spätestens jetzt
gewicht hoch und arbeiten und da ist
natürlich auch die schwere das gewicht
ist desto schwieriger wird diese ganze
übung achtet darauf wechselt die
richtung noch 15 sekunden jetzt und
entsprechend stabile position rücken
gerade nur das gewicht und die arme
bewegen sie der rest vom körper ist
ziemlich stabil vor allem die
wirbelsäule
doch jetzt gar nix neues muskulär
abgesichert so 1 zeit aus kurz
durchschlafen zweite übung war
der heiligenschein der bass zwar zum
eine zwar trainieren nicht wirklich ja
aber die übung hastet so da kann man nix
dafür den halo das drehen des gewichts
rund um den kopf
macht sich bereit im zehn sekunden legen
wir wieder los ja und dann geht es los
übung nummer zwei noch 52 uhr los geht's
kreisen des gewichts rund um den kopf
ich brauche gewisse beweglichkeit in
meiner schulter die kann ich damit
trainieren eine stabilität in den
gelenken nicht nur im rumpf sondern auch
in der schulter drinnen kennen seit die
richtung wechseln atmen und
konzentrieren die spannung darf nicht
verloren gehen
sei es durch arbeitszeit ist vorbei
gewicht wieder stabile position ablegen
aus lockern kurz durchschnaufen und ich
gesagt wir gehen in denen das aufrichten
des oberkörpers in den morgen hinein
erst wählt euer gewicht wieder so vor
dem körper jetzt noch einmal wichtig zur
zum zu nicht mitdenken die knie sind
beim aufheben gebeugt aber dann bei der
übung gestreckt okay das heißt wir
belasten hier hauptsächlich den unteren
rücken und das gehe am besten hin in dem
die knie durch strecke und entsprechend
nur den oberkörper nach vorbeuge und
wieder hoch wäre bereit die nicht in die
hand in 21 jetzt geht's los
ja aber die darf die bieten indem
bewegung lerne dich noch um 90 grad zu
drehen dass man ein sprechen
deine seite noch gut aussehen sehen sie
kunden drücken ist stabil der ist gerade
die schultern sind zurückgezogen die
brust ist draußen 21 pause und von der
vorbereitenden übung wo man mit den
rüttenscheider aktivieren gehen jetzt in
die komplexere übung in den raster
hinein
das heißt aus der position kniebeuge bis
in die position über kopf mit dem
gewicht die komplexeste übung jetzt
davon heute das heißt noch einmal
konzentrieren gewicht vorbereiten in
zehn sekunden gamersgate bereit
und los geht's achtet auf eure beinachse
achtet auf eure rumpf spannung front die
dynamik der bewegung sehr gut drei
sekunden und die wie ich da jetzt haben
wir noch vier übungen die letzten vier
übungen die grimmener gemeinsam hin wir
machen noch die sit ups die push übung
das hat die liegestütz pol-da zug und
den achter
dann haben wir das workout durch das
glamour gemeinsam hin konzentrieren
nächste übung sieht ups mit
zusatzgewicht zehn sekunden da gehen wir
wieder an frei zwei trends und los
geht's schön hochdrücken wichtig beine
bleiben am boden und die zweite variante
wenn sie in der gestreckten position
immer so gut funktioniert nimmt das
gewicht vor die brust ja dass er bislang
in der bewegung das ist mal klar aber es
ist für die bauchmuskulatur etwas
einfacher ok heimtückische weit drüber
34 sekunden und zeit ist aus 20 sekunden
belastung auch hagel herunter
hier wollen wir wechselten die push
variante das heißt der liegestütz
entweder an der auf der kette bell am
rucksack auf der tasche arme aus lockern
genau im kopf darauf vorbereiten es kann
man jetzt wirklich noch einmal 20 25
sekunden hohe belastung für die oberarme
gott die strecker muskulatur ist stark
gefordert in die position in fünf
sekunden gehts los
21 liegestütz jetzt
kenner stabile position gerade rücken
im optimalfall streckt die knie durch
dann hat es wirklich eine komplette
gerade wenn da leichter winkel drin ist
dann ist das jetzt für die oberarme
nicht ganz so tragisch weil sie konnten
nur 21 oder die letzten zwei übungen
eine zug übung rennicke 3 an der kette
bell und das rudern stehend in vorbeuge
mit dem zusatzgewicht dem rucksack der
tasche was auch immer
zwar übungen rudern und der achter
damals geschafft bereit machen
in fünf sekunden games wieder am 21
los geht's
das laktat einfach da kann man schon mal
die übungen verwechseln ist nicht
vertrage ich mache einfach kurz einfach
stabile position der becken stabil kommt
kämpft man die position ja wohl sekunden
21 und gut ist's gut ist ja die variante
zu kommen
drinnen das heißt double asthma dem
bizeps in der zug übung da belasten den
rückenmuskel den breiten rückenmuskel
mit also der sommer schon gut gut mit
dabei ok letzte übung der achter eine
beißen konzentrieren langsam aus einer
stabilen position heraus das ist das
absolut wichtige bereit fünf sekunden
und los geht's
schöne nacht zwischen den beinen durch
klarerweise muss man da breiter stehen
sonst kriegt man das gewicht nicht durch
der oberkörper ich stabil ist gerade und
nur in der dynamik der bewegung kann sie
das ein bisserl muskulär verhindern aber
es ist immer gut abgesichert noch fünf
sekunden 21 locken gewicht ablegen
ausschütteln die gelenke zu bewegen an
schluck trinken ja und dann macht man
mal kurz ist cool down
wir haben ist das sehr viel rum spanier
gehabt sehr für belastung in der entlang
der wirbelsäule und des locker meistert
zum schluss in unserem cool down ganz
kurzen hat bislang auf das heißt
regenerieren und dann wieder fit weiter
den tag bestreiten wie solch gegangen
herbert strengen sieht man ja gut
gemacht der eta kämpfer das schwierig
ist die stabilität im haus gehört bei
der kette pension war okay das heißt
wenn du irgendwann mit drei kräfte
genutzt haben zeigt ein handschuh oder
magnesium her beim rucksack war es
wahrscheinlich oder passagen etwa das
problem da ist eben weniger weibliche da
dass das aus der hand rutschen könnte ok
setzt sich bitte auf die matte knie
anwinkeln und die beine links und rechts
am boden das knie zum boden bewegen
genau da kriegen wir bislang mobilität
wieder in die lendenwirbelsäule hinein
ich sage ausspannen durchschnaufen arme
die beine ausstrecken leichter geöffnet
der credits und zehenspitzen nach innen
und nach außen hüftgelenke auflockern
und dann stehen wir noch mehr auf
spielte man den ganzen körper name
ausatmen normativ aus und ein jeder in
seinem rhythmus genau durchschnaufen
ausschütteln bisserl mobilisieren nur
bis und bewegen den oberkörper die
unterarme bisserl denen diese varianten
seien jetzt noch seine intensiven wirkt
wie balsam in dem verkauf der muskulatur
und auf den gelenken leute workout mit
zusatzgewicht mit dem rucksack mit der
kette bell für heute abgeschlossen ja es
war super cool das ist ja intensiv an
mittrainiert hat morgens sehen wir uns
zum nächsten training zum nächsten
workout wir sagen da wir freuen uns auf
euch und gemeinsam schaffen was
gemeinsam mit aus dem lokal